Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özübalı. Ich bin heute auf der Station als Assistent Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschäft durchführen. Alles in Ordnung?
Ja. Am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten und dann können wir weiterfahren. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Julia Kruger. Julia Kruger. Könnten Sie bitte Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja. J wie Julius, U wie Ulrich, L wie Ludwig, I wie Ida, A wie Anton.
Ja.
Mein Nachname buchstabiert sich K wie Kaufmann, R wie Richard, U wie Übamut, G wie Gustav.
Ü oder U?
Ü. U wie Übamut.
Übamut, ja.
Ja. Und G wie Gustav, E wie Emil, R wie Richard.
Alles gut, danke Ihnen. Frau Kruger, herzlich willkommen. Was für Sie sind Sie? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Vielleicht möchten Sie meine anderen Daten?
Ja, ja, ja. Entschuldigung, ich habe das vergessen.
Ja, ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Und was genau geboren Sie?
Ja, ich bin 45 Jahre alt und ich bin am 18.10.1979 geboren.
Können Sie bitte nochmal wiederholen?
Ja. Am 18.10.1979 geboren.
Am 18.10.1979, ja. Alles gut, vielen Dank. Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Kruger?
Herr Doktor, ich wiege 75,3 Kilo.
75,3 Kilo, wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, genau. Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 71 groß.
1 Meter 70 groß. Alles gut, danke. Frau Kruger, was für Sie zu uns?
Herr Doktor, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anpassen soll. Ich habe so viele Beschwerden.
Also ich fühle mich total müde und seit gestern habe ich Fieber. Irgendwie bin ich richtig schlapp.
Total müde. Seit gestern?
Ja, seit gestern habe ich Fieber.
Haben Sie Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe das gemessen. Es war 38,4.
38,4. Wo haben Sie das gemessen? Am Mond oder?
Warum ist das denn so wichtig, wo ich die Temperatur messe?
Es gibt es positionell unterschiedlich. Vielleicht ein bisschen hoch, Achilla, ein Grad Celsius weniger.
Ach so, ja klar. Ich habe im Mund gemessen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, seit gestern haben Sie die Beschwerden, Fieber und total Müdigkeit.
Eigentlich schon lange habe ich Müdigkeit, aber seit gestern ist es deutlich schlimmer, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich verstehe sehr gut. Und welche Beschwerden haben Sie seit wann?
Was meinen Sie? Ja, diese Beschwerden. Wie gesagt, habe ich schon lange Müdigkeit, aber seit gestern Fieber.
Ja, ich verstehe sehr gut. Vielleicht haben Sie es gemessen?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Und welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe viele Beschwerden. Meine Gelenke tun seit zwei Wochen weh.
Handgelenke oder?
Ja, nicht nur Hand, sondern auch meine Kniegelenke, beide Knie.
Beide Hände oder?
Ja, beidseitig. Alle Schmerzen beiseitig. Und seit ungefähr zwei Wochen, Herr Doktor.
Seit zwei Wochen, beidseitig.
Ja, voll.
Ich verstehe. Okay. Wie stammen die Schmerzen? Würden Sie mir beschreiben?
Das ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Wenn ich mich bewege, ist es so bei fünf.
Bei Bewegung würde ich eine fünf geben und in Ruhe vielleicht vier.
Auch eine Schmerzskala. Wo hin wissen Sie? Eine Schmerzskala.
Früher war ich ein Westischer.
Und Herr Doktor, besonders morgen sind diese Schmerzen... Ich habe Steifigkeit.
Es ist sehr schwer zu bewegen. Das dauert bestimmt eine halbe Stunde, bis es besser wird.
Steifigkeit und...
In meinen Kniegelenken, in meinem ganzen Körper. Wie gesagt, vor allem die Handgelenke und beide Knie.
Halbe Stunde. Danke für die Information. Das ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Die Steifigkeit ist regelmäßig und wann? Morgen oder?
Wie gesagt, morgens. Besonders morgens.
Und halbe Stunde. Nach der halben Stunde sind Sie ganz normal oder?
Ja, bis es besser wird. Dann wird es besser.
Gibt es eine Auslöser für die Schmerzen oder?
Das habe ich nie bemerkt. Ich weiß nicht. Aber manchmal sind die Finger leicht geschwollen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es normal ist, aber...
Haben Sie im Moment Schwierigkeit oder?
Jetzt nicht, aber manchmal. Besonders morgen früh.
Wie beschreiben Sie die Schwellung? Gibt es eine Farbeveränderung?
Nein, nur Schwellung habe ich bemerkt. Aber diese Schmerzen sind Zähne und manchmal Brennen.
Aber meistens Tieren.
Wie lange dauert die Schwellung?
Ich weiß nicht. Das habe ich nicht bemerkt. Nur Schwellen bemerkt.
Alles gut. Ich verstehe. Und dagegen haben Sie ein Medikament eingenommen oder?
Herr Doktor, es gab zu Hause Voltaren. Ich nehme das ein. Das hilft wirklich sehr. Geholfen.
Dann haben Sie schon Ihren Hausarztbesuch, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Für Medikamente gab es zu Hause. Aber unbedingt hat mein Hausarzt verschrieben.
Aber wegen dieser Beschwerden habe ich meinen Hausarzt besucht. Er dachte, er hat mich untersucht.
Er hat mir die Untersuchungen durchgeführt.
Dann dachte er, es sei vielleicht eine Infektion. Er hat mir geraten, in die Uniklinik zu gehen.
Deswegen bin ich hier.
Sie haben schon Ihren Hausarzt besucht.
Seit wann haben Sie Ihren Hausarzt besucht? Haben Sie schon gesagt, ich habe ihn nicht bemerkt?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich diese Beschwerden.
Vor zwei Wochen oder?
Seit fünf Jahren fühle ich mich nicht gut.
Ich habe vor zwei Monaten meinen Hausarzt besucht.
Es war sehr schwer, einen Termin zu finden in der Uniklinik.
Deswegen ist das der Grund für diese Spätung.
Voltaren, Tablet, hilft Ihnen?
Ja, wirklich sehr geholfen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Doktor, wie gesagt habe ich leider zu viel zu erzählen.
Ich habe hier über der Nase und auf den Wangen so eine Rötung.
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, habe ich schon bemerkt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Sie haben eine Rötung im Gesicht.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit etwa zwei Monaten.
Es wird schlimmer, wenn ich in der Sonne bin.
Es wird schlimmer, Herr Doktor.
Ihre Hauptveränderung, trocken oder nass?
Ja, trocken. Manchmal sind da so kleine Blättchen.
So kleine Blättchen.
Und gegen etwas Salbe oder andere Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, dagegen habe ich nie gemacht oder etwas probiert.
Und was noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, wie gesagt habe ich noch.
Manchmal habe ich auch so kleine schmerzhafte Stellen im Mund.
Im Mund?
Ja, früher.
Ja, kleine Schmerzhafte. Aber leider sind sie schmerzhaft.
Ich verstehe.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Ich meine vielleicht eine Atemnot oder Kopfschmerzen oder...
Nein.
Oder andere?
Gott sei Dank habe ich diese Beschwerden nicht.
Aber ich habe auch...
Ich schwitze besonders nachts.
In der Not?
Ja, nachts wache ich manchmal...
Ja, ich schwitze auch.
Okay.
Frau Kruger, haben Sie Übergabe erbrannt?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie ein Problem beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, Gott sei Dank. Kein Problem.
Beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, entweder Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang habe ich nicht.
Ja, alles gut.
Haben Sie Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen?
Wie gesagt, keine Beschwerden.
Keine Beschwerden.
Ja, beim Wasserlassen.
Alles gut.
Nur haben Sie schon gesagt, dass es gestern ein Fieber sei.
Nur Fieber? Nicht nur Fieber. Ich habe viele Beschwerden, Herr Doktor.
Ja, habe ich alle notiert.
Vielleicht...
Ich meine nur Vegetative.
Ob es wichtig ist, aber ich habe keinen Appetit, Herr Doktor.
Und ich habe in den letzten zwei Monaten abgenommen, ohne es zu wollen. Ist es auch wichtig?
Ja, natürlich.
Seit wann?
Innerhalb zwei Monaten habe ich etwa 4 Kilo.
4 Kilo abgenommen. Gewollt oder ungewollt?
Wie gesagt, ohne es zu wollen. Ungewollt.
Ungewollt.
Alles gut.
Und?
Ja, der Lust auf Vegetative und alles.
Haben Sie andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Aber meine Mandeln entzündet sich immer wieder.
Letztes Mal, vor zwei Monaten.
Ich habe viele Antibiotikum eingenommen.
Alles gut.
Ich habe Angst davor, dass diese Medikamente für meine Niere, für mein Leben schädlich sein können.
Ja, natürlich.
Es kann sein, Sie sollen immer mit einem ärztlichen Rad, einem Medikament benutzen.
Ohne ärztliche Rad. Ich empfehle Ihnen gar nicht.
Und, würden Sie mal operieren?
Nein, ich würde nicht operieren.
Okay.
Aber Herr Doktor, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es wichtig ist.
Ich habe zweimal mein Baby im Bauch verloren.
Ja.
Und ich verhüte.
Aber in der letzten Zeit sind meine Regelblutungen nicht mehr regelmäßig.
Seit wann?
Vielleicht in den letzten drei Jahren.
Haben Sie schon Ihren Frauenarzt besucht?
Leider nicht.
In der Kälte oder?
Ich bin jetzt 45 Jahre alt, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich bin 45.
Ja, ich besuche aber nicht regelmäßig.
Nicht regelmäßig, okay.
Ich nehme Kilen. Minolet.
Ja, Minolet.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Ja, wie gesagt nehme ich seit Voltaren 75 mg.
Voltaren?
Ja, um meinen Magen zu schützen, gleichzeitig nehme ich Pantoprazole 20 mg ein.
Okay, Pantoprazole 20 mg.
Voltaren nur bei Bedarf, nicht regelmäßig.
Und Minolet?
Minolet nehme ich jeden Tag. Wie gesagt verhüte ich, ja.
Verhüten wir.
Gut. Frau Krüger, haben Sie Allergien?
Herr Doktor, als ich Kind war, hatte ich eine Polenallergie.
Damals wurde mir eine eigene Bluttherapie empfohlen.
Aber meine Eltern wollten das nicht.
Damals war ich allergisch.
Ja, das ist aktuell keine Allergie.
Ja, ja.
Keine Allergien.
Keine Allergien. Keine Probleme mit Allergien.
Frau Krüger, leben Sie mit Ihrem Familie?
Ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich lebe mit meinem Mann und meinen zwei Töchtern.
Meine zwei Töchter.
Zwei Töchter, warten Sie. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Pädagogin, Herr Doktor. Ich arbeite in einer Grundschule als Pädagogin.
Alles gut.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Herr Doktor, mein Vater ist leider an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Aber zum Glück lebt meine Mutter.
Aber sie hat Gelenkräume.
Gelenkräume.
Röme, ja.
Röme.
Wissen Sie seit wann? Wie viele Jahre?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ihre Mutter.
Ich erinnere mich daran nicht.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester. Sie hat Schuppenflechte, Herr Doktor.
Schuppenflechte.
Ja, Schuppenflechte.
Unter Kontrolle oder?
Ja, ja. Sie besucht immer den Hautarzt.
Frau Kruger, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Herr Doktor, was habe ich? Was denken Sie?
Ich habe den Verdacht auf Systemik, Lupus, Deltamatos.
Wie soll ich sagen? Aber das ist nur eine Vermutung unter uns.
Ich würde bei Ihnen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Das klingt romantisch.
Ja, so wie ...
Wie meine Mutter.
Ihre Mutter und Ihre Schwester haben ähnliche Situationen.
Aber wir brauchen noch ein paar Untersuchungen.
Laboruntersuchungen, erstmal körperliche Untersuchungen, dann Laboruntersuchungen.
Und dann vielleicht bildgebende Untersuchungen.
Dann können wir wieder besprechen über Ihre Situation.
Okay. Danke Herr Doktor.
Alles gut. Bitte warten Sie hier.
Und dann, nach den 20 Minuten, bin ich wieder da.
Okay, ich warte auf Sie.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, wir sind die Systemik, Lupus, Deltamatos, und mein Fall, die Proofung.
Herr Doktor, Sie sind so genau vorbereitet, dass ich nicht mehr rauskriegen kann.
Ja, also, wenn man anfangs arbeitet, kann man alles verstehen und sich beherrschen.
Aber wenn man es tut, dann fragt man die ganzen Fragen oder man fragt sie nicht.
Naja, wir werden das am Ende noch sprechen.
Herr Özyilmaz, er ist auch ...
Ösyuval, Herr Doktor.
Ösyuval, okay.
Es gibt immer Probleme mit dem Schreiben, mit dem Digitieren usw.
Deswegen habe ich ihn selbst kürzer gemacht.
Okay.
Ösyuval.
Herr Özyuval, können Sie jetzt anfangen?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe meine Stellung.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Frau Oberstin, ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, möchte ich Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Es geht um Julia Kruger, 45 Jahre alt geboren, am 18.10.1979.
Sie wiegt 75,2 Kilo und sie ist 1,71 Meter groß.
Sie stellt sich heute bei uns wegen gestern ein Fieber und eine Totalmütigkeit.
Das Fieber 38,4 Grad C wurde im Mund gemessen.
Sie beschreibt seit zwei Monaten bei der Handgelenk und beidesseitigen Knie Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei Bewegung 5 von 10 und in Ruhe 4 von 10.
Er erwähnt noch ...
... Autosie.
Sie, Sie. Entschuldigung.
Sie klagt über morgens täglich ca. halbe Stunde dauernde Steifigkeit.
Keine bestimmte Auslöser.
Beideseitige Handgelenk und Beideseitige Knie haben Schwellung, Sehen und Brennende, Schmerzhaft.
Er nimmt ...
Er nimmt die Gelenken überwärmt oder gerötet?
Ja, ja.
Beide Handgelenk und Beideseitige Knie haben Schwellung, aber keine Farbeveränderung.
Beideseitige Handgelenk hat sie Sehen und Brennende Schmerzen.
Sie nimmt gegen diese Schmerzen Volta-Ran 75 mg.
Sie hat im Gesicht eine Rötung.
Beideseitige neben dem Mund und Wanken seit 3 Monaten.
Er beschreibt noch im Gesicht Püsten, die Püsten waren trocken und Blätchen.
Püsten oder Blätchen?
Püsten.
Ja, die Patienten haben Blätchen gesagt.
Und ansonsten die Vegetative-Annamen.
Sie haben seit ca. 2 Monaten 4 kg Ungewalt abgenommen und keine Appetit mehr.
Die Vegetative-Annamen sind unaufällig.
Als Vorerkrankungen leitet sie eine chronische Tonsillit, letztes Mal vor 2 Monaten.
Chronische oder seit 2 Monaten.
Aber es ist ein Residivierende.
Ja, es ist ein Residivierende.
Chronische Tonsillit.
Sie hat keine Operationen gesucht.
Sie nimmt regelmäßig Minulet-Tablet für die Verhautung.
Voltaren-Tablet 75 mg bei Bedarf und Pantoprasol 20 mg täglich.
Sie hat Polenallergie als Kind.
Sie wurde mit eigenem Bruttherapie therapiert.
Sind Sie sicher?
Wurde Polenallergie behandelt oder wollten Ihre Eltern die Polenallergie nicht und selbst verschwinden?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber die Patienten auch selbst.
Sie hatten als Kind eine eigene Bluttherapie.
Okay, ich habe gehört, vielleicht habe ich falsch gehört.
Die Patienten haben gesagt, der Arzt hat eine eigene Bluttherapie gegen Polenallergie empfohlen.
Aber ihre Eltern haben nicht angenommen.
Sie sind die Polenallergie selbst verschwunden.
Oder?
Genau so.
Selbst verschwunden.
Ich habe geträumt, weil wenn Sie nicht sicher sind, sagen Sie nicht.
Aber ich dachte ganz so.
Die Patienten haben gesagt, als Kind war ich Polenallergie und die behandelt mit eigenem Bluttherapie.
Ich verstehe das so.
Okay, wenn Sie das verstanden haben, sagen Sie so.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei Töchter.
Sie sind Pädagogin.
Der Vater ist verstorben durch Lungenkrebs.
Die Mutter leidet an Gelenkräumen.
Sie hat eine Schwester.
Die Schwester leidet an Schuppenflechten.
Was ist Schuppenflecht?
Auf Latein will ich es als Psoriasis nennen.
Ich habe den Verdacht auf ...
Vor der Verdachtdiagnose gibt es wichtige Informationen bei der genekologischen Amnese?
Ja, gibt es noch eine Weise.
Sie hat zweimal Fehlgeburt.
Okay, was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist systemische Lupus Eltomatosus.
Bei der Psydiagnose kommen Psyriatritis und Rheumatische Arthritis.
Okay.
Warum denken Sie an die Psydiatris?
Die Patientin hat eine typische Befunde im Gesicht.
Beide Seiten haben Rötung und Schmetterlinge.
Schmetterlinge, ja, diese Symptome sprechen für systemische Lupus Eltomatosus.
Aber meine Frage ist, warum Sie an Rheumatitis als Differentialdiagnose denken?
Die Mutter hat einen Gelenkräumer.
Die Schwester hat eine Psydiasisch Schuppenflecht.
Okay, gibt es wichtige Informationen bei der Anamnese?
Ja, gibt es viele wichtige Informationen.
Bei der Seite Handgelenkenschmerzen, bei der Seite Knie Schmerzen.
Und täglich morgen eine halbe Stunde Steifigkeit.
Sie haben eine halbe Stunde Steifigkeit und geschwollene Gelenke.
Natürlich Hand- und Kniegelenke-Aträge sprechen für Rheumatideatritis.
Neben der Schwester haben Sie auch eine halbe Stunde Steifigkeit.
Okay, welche Diagnos-Masnahmen würden Sie durchführen?
Ich würde gerne als erstes eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Am Anfang der Gezeche gibt es Pistole oder Bleche, Trocken oder Nass.
Und Vortungskarakter.
Und dann am Handgelenk.
Und dann die Schmerzen.
Und dann am Kniegelenk eine Hautveränderung, Schmerzintensität, Schwellung.
Bei der systemischen Untersuchung, Herzrhythmus, Geräusche und Lungenuntersuchung.
Und dann ...
Abhören des Herzes und der Lungen sind hier sehr wichtig wegen Komplikationen.
Nochmal bitte.
Abhören des Herzes und der Lungen sind sehr wichtig wegen Komplikationen des systemischen Stupus eratematodes.
Abhören des Herzes und der Lungen wegen Komplikationen.
Okay, noch weiter.
Und dann die Labo-Untersuchung.
Ich würde gerne eine Labo-Untersuchung durchführen.
Blutbild und Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, CAP und Blutköpfchen-Senkung, Geschwindigkeit.
Sehr wichtig. Und ...
Meinen Sie BSG?
Ja, BSG.
Ich glaube, diese Werte werden nicht sehr oft überprüft.
Momentan.
Als Entzündung parametern wird CRP kontrolliert oder überprüft.
Ich habe ein paar Erfahrungen gelesen.
Wenn wir BSG nennen, dann kritisiert der Prüfer oder die Prüferin.
In der Aufnahme überprüfen wir keine BSG.
Sie können nur CRP nennen.
Okay.
Jeder Not hat BSG geschrieben.
Ja, am Anfang habe ich alle geschrieben.
Aber dann habe ich viele verschiedene Erfahrungen gelesen.
Und mache ich ein paar Veränderungen.
Danke für die Information.
Und ...
Wegen systemischer Lupus automatosis,
Anti-nuklear Antiköpfchen,
Anti-DSDNA Antiköpfchen und
und spezifisch Antisemit Antiköpfchen.
Dann ...
Ja, das war mein Ruhm.
Kompliment C3, C4?
Nein, nein.
Noch mehr Kompliment, Test C3, C4.
Okay. Welche operativen Methoden würden Sie durchführen?
Operativen Methoden ...
Erstes Teil ist ...
... gluckokortgut.
Nein, nein. Als operativen Methoden.
Operativen?
Zum Beispiel Bildgebende werfen oder andere ...
... außer Blutabnahme oder ...
... Körperleuntersuchung.
Möchten Sie auf andere Methoden?
Ja, andere ...
... würde ich gerne einen EKG schreiben.
Herzunterzuchtung ist sehr wichtig.
Und dann ein Rücken, Handgelenk, Hand oder Knie.
Oder Hand und Knie.
Hand und Kniegelenke.
Was noch? Könnten Sie mir bitte helfen?
Ja, Sie sind sehr wichtig.
Aber wenn die Patientin ...
... Mixionbeschwerden hat ...
... können Sie Ultraschall des Nierens durchführen?
Ja, ja, ja. Natürlich.
Visualisatnidae Prüfung SLE oder ...
... Systemische Lupusertomatodes.
Visualisatnidae Prüfung.
Systemische Lupusertomatodes.
Keine Abkursung.
Wenn die Patientin auf ...
... Luftnot oder Lungenprobleme genannt hat ...
... würden wir auf Röntgen-Torax durchführen.
Aber es ist ein Standard.
Herzunterzuchtung, ein EKG und ...
... EKG, Röntgen.
Und ein Nierenultraschall.
Nierenfunktionen sind auch sehr wichtig.
Die häufigsten Komplikationen sind der Nierenbefall.
Deswegen sollen wir einen Nierenultraschall durchführen.
Ja, Immunkomplex.
Lagerung bei der Glamour.
Glamourle Körption oder ...
Ja, Ansammlung.
Ja, Immunkomplexen.
Würden wir auf Kums-Test durchführen?
Ja, Kums-Test ist ... habe ich vergessen.
Es ist ein Standard.
Positiv für die CLE Kums-Test.
Nicht immer, aber ...
... wenn ...
... wenn das Befall der Blut ...
... vorhanden ist ...
... erwarten wir positive Kums-Tests. Ja.
Okay, wie können Sie ...
... die Patienten behandeln?
Ätzt immer mit einer Kugelgurt.
Dann ...
... nicht so lange.
Anti-Rheumatik ...
... dann Hydroxychloroquin.
Noch ...
... Azatopin oder Methotrexat.
Dann ...
... sp4.
Würden Sie die Patienten stationär aufnehmen oder ambulant behandeln?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich würde gerne diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Warum?
CLR hat seit zwei, drei Monaten endliche Beschwerden, sogenannte Beschwerden.
Und dann sollen sie für die Kontrolle auf jeden Fall die Station aufnehmen und dann kontrollieren.
Ok. Seit langer Zeit hat sie viele Beschwerden und CLR beeinflusst alle systemischen Organen.
Deswegen müssen wir viele Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich habe gedacht...
Ich wollte etwas sagen, Herr Prof.
Ich habe die Säle geteilt.
CLR ist ein System, das alle Organe beeinflusst.
Ich verstehe.
Aber ich habe es nicht gesagt.
Jetzt versuche ich, Sie zu sagen, wie Sie es sagen können.
Ich habe dort ein Kartelein.
Wenn wir nicht in die Säle gehen, werden wir verbreitet.
Herr Prof.
CLR beeinflusst alle Organe im Körper.
Ich bin ein Schwerpunkt.
Ok. Dann, Herr Prof.
Können Sie etwas sagen, Herr Prof.
Natürlich.
Vielleicht ist es nicht so für die anderen 21 Fakten, aber weil Clut, Zenkung, Eschwind und Schleif ein romantisches Problem sind, ist es wichtig,
dass wir das nicht machen.
Ich denke, dass es ein romantisches Problem ist.
Danke.
Ihr könnt es, Herr Prof.
Hallo, Herr Prof.
Ich kann Ihnen etwas vorstellen.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin und darf Sie mir etwas vorstellen?
Natürlich.
Es handelt sich um Julia Krueger.
Sie ist 45 Jahre alt und am 18.1979 geboren.
Sie ist ungefähr 75,3 Kilo und sie ist 1,71 Meter groß.
Frau Krueger kam heute zu uns wegen gestern Fieber.
Seit gestern Fieber und seit zwei Wochen Beizeitgehemdkniegelenkel Schmerzen.
Schmerzintensität bei der Bewegung von 5 von 10 auf der NRS, aber im Ruhe von 4 von 10 Intensität.
Sie hat seit langer Zeit Müdigkeit, aber ihre Beschwerden sind in ungefähr zwei Wochen schlimmer geworden.
Außerdem hat sie manchmal geschwollene Gelenken, aber ohne Rötungen.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie heißt.
Darüber hinaus hat sie Rötungen neben den Wangen und Nasen seit drei Monaten.
Diese Beschwerden sind mit Sonnenstrahlung schlimmer geworden.
Ihre Körpertemperatur war 38,4 Grad Celsius im Mund.
Sie hat in Abhedenz, innerhalb von drei Monaten, ungefähr 4 Kilo abgenommen.
Frau Krueger hat unregelmäßig Blut in den letzten drei Jahren und sie hatte zweimal Fällgeburt.
Als Vorerkrankungen hat Frau Krueger ein Residivierende, Tom Silitis, und sie wurde manchmal in der Ambulanz vielmals behandelt.
Sie hat vielmals Antibiotikatherapie angenommen.
Als Medikamenten nehme sie regelmäßig Minuletz, eine Tablette morgens, und Voltaren 75 mg regelmäßig, und Pantoprosol 20 mg morgens, eine Tablette.
Sie hat keine Operation und hatte eine Polenallergie.
Sie wurde in der Zeit verlaufen selbstgesunden.
Soziell anlässlich ist sie Pädagogin und hat zwei gesunde Tochter.
Frau Krueger hat erwähnt, dass ihr Vater Lungenkrebs und er ist verstorben.
Ihr Mutter hat Arthritis und ihr Schwester hat Psoriasis.
Nach den anästischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine systemische Lupus-Edytamotode.
Die Diagnostik der Pädagogin ist auch eine Arthritis und eine Infektionsarthritis.
Ich werde die Patienten körperlich untersuchen und überwachen die Vitalparameter.
Als Routine sollte ein EKG geschrieben werden. Im Labor würde ich Blutbildentzündung, Leberparameter, Nierenparameter kontrollieren.
Ein Rundengelenk sollte dann verhandelt werden.
Ich werde die Patienten aber auch operativ untersuchen.
Ich werde ein römantologisches Konsil beantworten. Danke.
Ich werde die Patienten beantworten.
Ich habe das als Zeichen gesehen.
Das kann als Komplikation der Patienten sein.
Ich habe eine Frage für Tungu und seine Mutter gefragt, um die Komplikation zu erwerben.
Dann geht es weiter, wie ihr wisst.
Ich habe diese Fragen gefragt.
Seyre ist eine der einfachsten Fakade des Düsseldorfs.
Denn er hat nicht viel Reaktion von sich selbst.
Er hat nicht extra was zu den Fakaden zu sagen.
Er hat mir nur gesagt, dass seine Mutter Arthrose ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich auch Arthrose werde.
Meine Mutter hat mir gesagt, dass sie sich damit etwas für mich verabschieden.
Ich habe ihr gesagt, dass ich Angst habe.
Aber ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass ihre Bewerber nicht zu Arthrose passen.
Aber keine Sorge, wir werden alle wichtigen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und die genaue Ursehe und die genaue Diagnose zu erzählen, sind die Ursehe zu finden.
So etwas habe ich gesagt.
Wenn ich diese Fakade nicht mache, habe ich meine eigenen Reaktionen versucht.
Als ich sie zu Beginn der Fakade erwähnt habe, war sie nicht zu betrachten und sie wurden damit verabschieden.
Oder was habt ihr über Reaktionen zu fragen?
Was haben sie in Arsene gefragt?
Ich habe dort alle geschrieben, ich erinnere mich nicht.
Ich habe alle Fragen auf Karte geschrieben, die sie mir angetan haben.
Aber ich kann sie noch mal ausrechnen.
Ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt.
Sie stellt sich bei uns wegen der bestehenden Fieber und Atrallgie vor.
Laut Auslage der Patienten ist die Atrallgie an Handgelenk und Kniegelenk.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bei Bewegung und 4 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala in der Ruhe.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen sichern, persistierend und progredient sind.
Sie berichtet, dass sie seit 5 Monaten Schubweise diese 5 werden.
Ich habe sie in der Ruhe gefragt.
Sie hat mich gefragt, was Atrallgie bedeutet.
Schmerzende Gelenke.
Das ist die Schmerzende Gelenk.
Sie hat mich gefragt, ob sie das oder das nicht so genannt sind.
Die Schmerzen verschlemmen sich bei Bewegung, während die Einnahme von Diclofenac, 75 mg, und Hochbeinlagerung besser.
Ich habe hier die Schmerzverdienung, aber ich sage immer, dass ich die Schmerzen mit dem Auslöser nenne.
Ich verbreite die Schmerz, die Schmerzintensität, sie berichtet, dass sie seit 5 Monaten Schubweise diese 5 werden.
Ich habe hier die Schmerzverdienung, die ich in der Dokumentation verwendet habe.
Das ist sehr hilfreich für die Schmerzverdienung.
Ich habe die Schmerzverdienung, die ich in der Dokumentation verwendet habe, verwendet.
Habt ihr die Schmerzverdienung in der Dokumentation verwendet?
Natürlich.
Nicht die Schmerzverdienung, sondern die Schmerzverdienung.
Nein, nein, ich habe die Schmerzverdienung als Schmerzverdienung verwendet, weil sie mir selbst gesagt hat.
Was hat der Patient mir in der Dokumentation gesagt?
Ich habe die Schmerzverdienung verwendet, wenn er mir das schon gesagt hat.
Aber wenn er es mir nicht gesagt hat, dann habe ich es in der Dokumentation verwendet.
Ich kann es dir sagen.
Ich habe versucht, das zu sagen, aber es kann nicht so richtig sein.
Ich nenne die Schmerzverdienungen, die ich verwendet habe.
Wissen Sie, dass Sie an den Danish-Gespräch teilnehmen?
Nein, ich habe noch nicht getroffen. Ich warte, dass ich dort teilnehmen werde.
Es gibt eine Gruppe, die auf Danish-Gespräche steht.
Da hat der Danish-Gespräch die ganze Art und Weise, die man in einer Sitzung sagt, nicht richtig.
Die Prüfer haben auch gesagt, dass sie nicht gefällt.
Ich habe drei Sätze aus Ihren Sätzen gemacht.
Ich habe das gemacht, weil es mir richtig ist.
Was Sie gemacht haben, ist nicht falsch.
Aber der Danish-Gespräch hat mir nicht so geholfen, dass ich das nicht so mache.
Du hast so viele, sechs, sieben Informationen in einem Moment.
Du hast es in einem Moment geschafft.
Du denkst so, aber du hast die Zeit kurz.
Du kannst dann noch ein paar Fragen haben.
Ich werde es mal evaluieren. Danke.
Ja, das ist so.
Das ist nicht falsch.
Ich habe die Zuhörungen von Schmetterlinge ergriffen.
Was haben sie gesagt?
Sie hat erwähnt, dass sie seit zwei Monaten, besonders nach der Sonne,
Hautrötung im Gesicht auf dem Wagen und über die Nase hat.
Ich habe ihn mir als Kranke beantwortet.
Er hat mir die Fahbegriffen gefragt.
Dann habe ich ihn zu Schüpunflehte gesagt.
Er hat nicht die Fahbegriffen, sondern die Fahbegriffen.
Aber ich habe ihn auch gesagt.
Dann habe ich den Patienten extra gebeten.
Ich bin sehr verabschiedet.
Schümeire hat die Operarsel erzielt.
Dann hat er mich als Kranke beantwortet.
Ich habe gesagt, dass es eine Tonsillitis ist.
Warum ist das möglich?
Ich habe gesagt, es kann eine Komplikation der Lupus sein.
Systemische Lupus-Ertemotodes beeinflussen viele Systemische Organe.
Zum Beispiel Blut und kann Panstopen verursachen.
Wahrscheinlich hat sie deswegen eine Komplikation,
die sie von mir beantworten wollen.
Sie haben mir die Frage gefragt, warum sie Panstopen hören.
Sie haben mir die Frage gefragt, welche Organe sie beitragen und welche Komplikationen sie verursachen.
Dann habe ich sie gefragt, was Schüpunflehte sind.
Schüpunflehte sind die Schüpfel, die die Schüpfel in der Hand halten.
Ich habe sie jetzt noch erinnert.
Ich habe sie in einer Note geschrieben.
Ich glaube, es gibt noch weitere Fragen.
Ich erinnere mich an diese.
Danke, Herr Professor.
Vielen Dank für das.
Es war eine sehr verheiratende Situation.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie noch weitere Fragen?
Es gibt noch viele Fragen, Herr Professor.
Die Fragen und Erfahrungen, die Sie in den Noten geteilt haben, sind hier.
Sie haben alle eine Anleitung, Herr Professor.
Ich möchte sie wieder sagen.
Ich habe die Noten in meinem eigenen Übungsprozess geteilt.
Sie können sehr genau sein.
Ich habe sie zuerst in der Arbeit gemacht,
und ich habe sie nicht so genau wie möglich gemacht.
Aber ich glaube, das muss man so machen.
Wenn man zuerst etwas fehlt, kann man etwas anderes machen.
Ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute.
Bis morgen.
Tschüss.